the pitch was essentially these two
movies about perspective which come out
October 10 and that's what we started
with and his third movie was born from
that this year actually in the editing
room but yeah I you know when I started
doing this oh god you know eight or nine
years ago with Jessica and my producer
Cassandra I mean we that's why I took
eight or nine years it's a tough pitch I
made it easy on myself as a first-timer
this moved this title song must have
haunted you as a character and in your
imagination for all these years yeah I
think um I while I was outlining the
film I was just listening to the song
and it fused the script with you know
the mood of the piece that I wanted all
the lonely people where they all come
from and I think in the expanded version
of this movie you know I looked at all
of these characters going through their
own quiet crisis I think everybody you
know has their own thing that they're
going through aside from these two
people and and and they all cope in
different ways and I just wanted to
explore that and I used a very extreme
case of in terms of what the tragedy is
when I started doing this I wanted to
make a film about a relationship
essentially a love story and I thought
the best way to do that was to write two
separate points of view two separate
movies that show the same context the
same time period from you know the male
and the female perspective so I think
with Jessica and Cassandra we sort of i
had this him script that I started with
and then Jess started asking me
questions about this character Eleanor
Rigby and where does she go and that
sort of opened up this idea for me to
explore that and and and and sort of
make a fully well-rounded you know love
story from both points of view and
ultimately the truth lies somewhere in
the middle I rode a 223 page script
which is ridiculous as a first timer so
the script is 223 pages I'm a first-time
director with a couple shorts jessica is
unknown
this point Cassandra's been a casting
director and she's the lead producer on
it the odds were absolutely ridiculous
and I think you know thank goodness that
Jessica's career took off because she
got the Terrence Malick film tree of
life somewhere right around the point
where we started working on this and and
that really I think helped start moving
things forward you met when she
essentially stalked you right at the
mouth festival yeah 11 years ago I had a
short film my first work from played at
the Santa Monica Lemley and they're like
12 people in the audience and all of
them are the filmmakers and we walked
out after I had finished there were like
four films that played back to back and
and this girl comes running up to me and
she goes I want to work with you and I
was like what do you mean she's like
will you directed that film right and I
was like yeah and she was like well I
want to work with you and I was like why
and essentially she was like no I really
liked your film and I was like well
that's cool and she's like my name is
Jessica Chastain and she just graduated
Juilliard she'd done an episode of ER
and that was it and she sent me that and
then invited me to go see a play that
she was doing in New York with David's
truth Aaron called Rodney's wife and I
saw her walk out on stage in that and I
was just like blown away by how amazing
she was and you know we became friends
and very close and and then ultimately
you know started making this project
together I don't know where to begin to
ask about how you shoot two films at the
same time well we we treated it as one I
treated it as one script one project one
story and we shot the 223 pages in 40
days in New York two years ago so that I
just had a great crew and I had a great
group of people and I think we were just
as organized as we possibly could be and
those overlapping scenes we treated as
separate scenes so I think the
phenomenal thing that the actors did was
that it especially Jessica and James is
that they not only played the character
Jessica played the character of Eleanor
Rick
but then she turns around and plays his
perception of her in a different scene
that is exactly the same scene in the
sense and he does the same thing so they
had to play two characters and they did
such a beautiful job because like that
scene at the apartment at the end of the
film when they're on the floor we had to
shoot that scene twice and we did it in
different production design different
costumes like we do that scene once and
they've emotionally exhausted themselves
and then we have to go to lunch turn
around reset up and do it all again in a
completely different way with a
different intention and they nail it
again so i think the emotional place is
that those two actors were going in the
amount of work that they ruin was just
like ahh inspiring to all of us how did
you balance the the power and the force
of each personality on film I think look
there's a generosity to the way Jessica
works and I think she was a producer on
the phone so I think you know she I
think she met with James pretty much
immediately once he signed on and the
two of them had their own sort of lunch
together and I think that was really
helpful and then I I had a rehearsal we
actually went to grab a beer the three
of us and started looking through the
script and talking through the scenes
and I think there was just a this sort
of camaraderie that existed between the
two of them that you know is sort of an
intangible you sort of you hope when you
sit down with these people that there
will be chemistry regardless and the two
of them just had this amazing chemistry
from the gecko you know they could they
were clipping and laughing and teasing
each other and you know I was sending
them each music and they were sort of
sharing that music you know there was
there was a whole lot going on it I
think when you make films this small
like it becomes like camp in a way I
think there's a it's a much more
familial experience and you know I I
really love these two people now I mean
they've been so wonderful to me and they
gave me the gift of being able to make
this film because without them you know
and and my producer like I wouldn't be
sitting here talking to you about it I
really lucked into this this composer
because there was another composer that
it was initially supposed to do it named
anthony gonzalez who goes by the name of
m 83 and
he was busy doing the Oblivion score at
that point and kind of different from
this very different and he just felt he
was working on an album and he was like
a look I'm too busy and his manager /
agent was like look I have this diamond
in the rough I'd love you to at least
like talk with him and like hear stuff
so I spoke with them and and I asked him
to do some sketches based on the movie
because he really responded to the
two-part and he came back with this
these sketches that were based on
objects that existed within the film so
he created a score based in wine glasses
or corrugated metal or you know things
that existed within the space of you
know that was in camera and and
ultimately I got to work with him on a
score which I don't think I would have
had the chance to with other people and
be as collaborative with him so that was
really exciting what you mean you
actually played the garbage candidates I
didn't play the garbage can lid i was
just like more garbage cans cans and and
did you want it it points to be not even
musical which it was at moment was I
mean I I wanted very spare amounts of
score in the film I wanted to feel the
silences and let the acting do the work
as opposed to have score dictate the
emotional space but I think that's even
more apparent in the other two films in
this film I I got to add a little bit
more score and and have a soundscape I
think we all lose people in our lives
its kind of the tragedy and you know of
being a human being it i think we all go
through loss we all go through this
thing and and you know and this is a
very extreme case I it was based on
something personal that happened to me
not as extreme as this but you know
something that poor apart a relationship
and you know I coped in one way and the
other person coped in another way and I
I think that was sort of what I wanted
to try and articulate that was the thing
that I didn't understand that was the
thing that I think was interesting to me
in terms of trying to capture on film or
at least express is because we're all
very different people you know who deal
with things in very different ways and
there's nothing wrong with that that's
just at the end of the day you can be
angry yourself because you dealt with
something in one way but once time has
passed once you're beyond it you realize
you were doing all that you could at the
time and that was the way that you
needed to deal with it and you can't be
angry at another person you know for
dealing with it in one way it's just the
way that they were coping and I think we
all do that whether it's you know
getting in a fight really silly fight at
home over you know I don't know who left
the TV on versus like you know something
as Extreme is this but I think I just
wanted to look at relationships and how
you know how we cope is individuals and
and and how how ultimately there is no
right or wrong